for me honestly
putting any amount of makeup on my face
is too much
excessive contouring where girls
literally look like they're changing the
bone structure of their face like that's
talent but like also that's not
you
i'm passionate of makeup because it
allowed me to showcase to the world at a
very young age the woman that i
always was a lot of people think just
because i wear makeup i'm really stuck
up
and i feel like i'm the best at
everything we're just normal people that
like to look good in person and just
look good for everyone
i think that the beauty industry really
prioritizes eurocentric beauty standards
even in pursuit of trying to be
beautiful and love myself or be loved by
others
i will never fulfill those eurocentric
beauty standards
i stopped wearing makeup either during
my freshman year
of college or my sophomore year of
college and i feel more like my
authentic self when i'm not wearing it
people say it's too much
or try to say they're going to wipe it
off or
you know just judge you for wearing it
but maybe don't know why you do
my mom expected me to just always look
dolled up that would be her idea of
looking beautiful
i think that kind of turned me off a
little bit from from makeup and
i just like how i look naturally
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is sabrina and i'm from the bay
area and i can't wait to learn your
guys's opinion about makeup
my name is chris and i'm so excited to
talk with you guys about makeup
i'm la demi and i'm excited to debate
with you guys
my name is theo and i'm excited to have
this conversation with all of you guys
hi my name is bryn and i'm just excited
to hear some different perspectives
hi my name is alina and none of my
friends really wear makeup so i'm
excited to see what everyone thinks
about it and where their opinions come
from
women are oppressed by today's beauty
standards
it praise or it being the beauty
industry and the cosmetic industry
preys on the insecurities that women
and men as well feel for example with
aging
wear this foundation use these eye
creams do this that the other thing so
that way
you don't look like you're aging and i
think that
the aging process is a beautiful thing
and it should be celebrated and it just
shows like all of the life that you've
lived and
our skin and our faces they all tell a
story
the way that i see it oppressing women
and men alike
is shaming them into thinking that
they have to present themselves in a way
that's deemed
the ideal or the standard i think the
sole fact that there
is a beauty standard in general
is just so damaging because i just see
beauty in a lot of people
there shouldn't be a standard for your
natural self that you are
i don't necessarily think beauty
standards are oppressive but i think
sometimes they're unobtainable
so for example like i've always
struggled with acne scars and i was like
looking on social media and everybody's
skin looks like
so even and so clear but then i learned
that there are a lot of filters that
will actually do that like i only
discovered this two months ago
and then i used one and i was like wait
no i look like everybody else
and i thought everybody just had like
beautiful poreless skin and i was the
only one left out
when you guys will post like your makeup
look
do you guys use filters on them i've
always been open
with all my followers that i edit my
pictures and face tune them just because
it just gives them that extra like
feeling to the picture
but not like enhanced like nose or eyes
or anything like that
that's the same thing i'd smooth the
texture unless you see me in person
honey you're not going to see these
scars or
this texture or anything like that i'm
going to filter it out
but sometimes photos are clearly it's
obvious that i'm using a filter
so i would hope that someone doesn't
think that i look exactly like this
because it's clearly a filter if it's
becoming too challenging
being online seeing you know the
different
types of beauty that's all over the
world then maybe social media is not for
you right now because you're still
discovering who you're meant to be i
used to be uh i had a little
self-esteem so i was really crazy with
like you know the photoshopping and
everything and
as i grow into myself i just grew to
love but as far as filtering like my
makeup looks or whatever
um there's always going to be a little
smooth here and there
a woman's hair is full it's cooling
it does something a little smooth here
i guess the reason why i asked that
question is because in a lot of like
makeup ads
they'll do the makeup look and then
change the makeup look in photoshop but
it just seems like it sets unrealistic
expectations a for the product and b
what it's going to make you look like
makeup has changed how i'm treated by
people
pre-covered days i love to go out to
dance and stuff to go to the club
just men tend to just give me a lot more
attention
when i'm wearing makeup and i don't know
it just doesn't
feel it doesn't feel good to me and i
swear
and i'm not wearing it not a peep comes
no one no one comes my way i think i
like the ladder i like
no one coming up to me or they just come
up to me just because they like my
energy
or something like that but i've just
gotten different treatment for wearing
makeup
and it hasn't ended positively sometimes
since i am like
all over social media and like tv and
stuff when people
expect me to show up and show face they
expect to glam and they expect the
makeup and if i do show up without any
of that it's just like
no one was like where's the star where's
the star power where's la demi
you know i kind of feel the same way on
social media
all i have on is makeup and then on my
normal days i'm like just a regular boy
so when i go to like sephora or makeup
shopping they're just like oh
is he going to steal something because
you know something that's what they
mostly think of when you're not like in
full glam or you look bummy
or he's going to steal something because
he's looking suspicious looking at the
makeup products but once i like go in
with like a full face
they kind of leave me alone because i'm
going back to that point where oh he
knows what he's doing because he has a
full glam
i don't know if you've read about the
attractiveness bias what's the idea that
pretty people are like perceived as like
more welcoming
more educated um so i've definitely gone
into interviews or like heard my
employer talk about people and it's not
that they'll say like oh she wasn't
wearing makeup they'll say like
she didn't seem as ready or like she
wasn't as put together i used to only
wear makeup
pretty much for interviews or if i was
on camera i didn't want to give them a
reason to not hire me
i used to wear like a lot of makeup i
was never good at it like oh you guys
look amazing
i was never good at it but i used to
wear a lot and then ultimately at some
point
makeup comes off you know and beneath
that you're still you
it's not easy to accept that sometimes
in the moments that i was kind of
transitioning to not really wearing
anymore
i really didn't notice any difference in
the way that people treated me
maybe that's just because the people
that i'm surrounded by
are really accepting and i know that
that's not the case for everyone else
i'm trying to love myself without makeup
in kind of my default state i guess
and makeup certainly makes me feel very
like empowered and beautiful
but then i almost like resent myself
more when i take it off so i don't know
what that's been like for you i'm a
competent person
so i can still go without and still feel
for her it's definitely like a
like a superpower i always say makeup
because when i
when i'm in makeup i just feel like i
have a cape on and i can do anything
and without it it kind of humbles me
down to maybe
not be that person in the room to ask a
question or you know it's kind of like
my backup dancer
yeah i agree on with la demi um when i
have makeup i just feel like i could
conquer like the whole world and i'm
just like that person that can do
anything
that's like the main reason why i go
into makeup because it just makes you
feel good
into a sense wearing makeup you kind of
have to have be confident for someone
that
puts makeup on to feel good about
themselves or whatever but at the same
time you need to be confident because
it's going to attract that attention
right i don't know how i feel about that
to be honest because i think like
for a long time like when i didn't wear
makeup i would be like i feel so bad
that people have to look at me when i
choose to wear makeup it's not because i
feel confident but i'm almost like
can this make me feel confident
objectively i look better like i look
brighter and so
in the moment of being transformed
physically maybe emotionally i can say
like
let me go out into the world with more
conviction as much as makeup empowers me
i also want to be empowered
in my authentic form as well i have felt
uncomfortable
leaving home without makeup
i don't feel uncomfortable about leaving
home without makeup
now but i think it took me a while to
get to this point
there's still a part of my brain in my
subconscious that's like
well maybe just a little bit maybe maybe
just just a little something
back in the day it was more based on
just insecurity that i wasn't good
enough without any makeup
and now i think i've i've worked pretty
hard to get
get to this point um sometimes for me i
do feel uncomfortable because you know i
just want to have like
nice skin like out in public or like a
full glam out in public
but something i don't want to deal with
like people just staring me down or like
little kids coming up to me and be like
why are you wearing makeup that's
for girls so i just sometimes don't even
go out with makeup
that much when i started to wear makeup
and
i was you know being perceived to the
public as a woman
without it i wasn't you know so it was
like really
hard to adjust to even leaving my house
without a lash without an eyebrow
without some kind of lip gloss or blush
or something to give me that touch to
feel like
you know i'm not going to get
misgendered out there in the world i am
trans and i definitely know what it
feels like to
not be able to leave the house without
something to
validate me as a woman to society
i think the only time i used to
regularly wear makeup is like if i
thought i'd see my ex or something like
that
um but also when i was going on a lot of
first dates before i met my girlfriend i
would like
it would pretty much be the only time
i'd wear makeup like i wouldn't wear it
to work and i would come home and put it
on
but then i started to realize like these
people like if it goes further they're
going to see me without makeup and i'd
almost
rather have them know that up front and
actually the first date i went on with
my girlfriend was like one of the first
first dates i didn't wear makeup because
i just felt like i trusted her
i just knew that i could trust her so
funny to like bounce off of that
i went through like a phase two where
like i would like spend the night with a
guy and i would not take off my makeup
like
i was sleeping my makeup and even like
10 minutes before like waking up waking
up i'd run back to the restroom
touch up put on a lip stain so i would
wake up like
i used to before we were boyfriend and
girlfriend
i used to sleep in my makeup and makeup
all over this dude's pillow
so on valentine's day he asked me this
girlfriend and i was like i'm about to
wash my face
because i want to just take it all off
and see what happens and so
i did that and i'm like still kind of
trying to hide
but i he saw me and then after that i'm
just like
on facetime now i'm just comfortable for
me it was kind of the opposite
when you're a gay guy trying to get a
boyfriend out there most of the guys
don't want a guy that's wearing makeup
so i would hide everything about me like
wearing makeup um
when i was talking um with my boyfriend
at that time i was trying to hide them
like my pictures on instagram
i would literally delete them so he
won't know that i was wearing makeup or
into
makeup but then once i told him he was
like really accepting
and now like he actually helps me like
film my youtube videos
i asked him if it looked good he was
like oh my god you look so bomb
altering your skin color is cultural
appropriation
okay right
yeah it's the act of blackface black
fishing and all of that
i don't understand why people are doing
it they're blaming you know no
i'm darker in the summer i'm all but
just like
you're literally using compared to your
face to your body
a whole different shade different
people's skin tones will change
throughout the year depending on the
weather and the amount of sun that
they're in
but there's obviously a very sincere
line and when the issue of black fishing
comes into play when people are
presenting themselves as more
ethnically ambiguous because it's trendy
that's not okay when i was in high
school it was like a very white
high school essentially and i remember
somebody like wrote a note to me that
was supposed to be nice and they said
you have that beautiful tan skin that i
long for and i was like what is this
white girl saying to me
like and i like i didn't even know how
to react because i think it was meant to
be a compliment like my skin is not like
a commodity like my brownness is not up
for you to take
and claim as your own as you so please
like let's say you're doing a shoot out
in the like the desert
and like you're doing like a warrior
shoot it's just an example they're
obviously gonna like bronze you up and
like
airbrush you and make you look more
tanner because they're not gonna want
you like not like bronzy in the desert
because that just kind of
doesn't make sense i always get spray
tans to be you know better at looking on
camera
as to just looking 10 and you know when
you're 10 you feel sexier you look
slimmer
but i think there's definitely a fine
line between looking 10 and then taking
it to extreme to you don't even look
like
you your race you know but i remember
there was also a brand that
they made a model look significantly
darker because some but they had
they had been asked to be like have more
diversity and instead of actually
finding a darker skin model they made a
lighter skin person darker
for this campaign a lot of the black
fishing examples that i've seen have
been young girls
the intent for those girls comes
back to the idea that they feel it's
more like a psychological issue i don't
think their intent is
i want to appropriate you know the skin
color of a different race i think it's
just
man for some reason right now in the
media the trend
is to be to be darker skinned i remember
in the 2000s the fair skinned
skinny girl look was in and trends have
just changed so i believe
girls have that idea that they just want
to be that and be more accepted
if they do something wrong at all in the
media nowadays
the backlash is they do not forgive that
person
i just don't think that the dialogue is
is
healthy or helpful and progressive for
all people of different races to be
united
i think there was some commentary from
like asians and asian americans about
like the fox citroen even i feel like
the name
the make the eye shape that a lot of
like asians have i definitely have heard
people kind of be offended by that
because they've made been made fun of
been called racial slurs for being like
whatever asian form of asian or asian
american they are
i had surgery obviously on my face
ffs facial feminization surgery and i
used to have
really masculine you know sad hooded
eyes
and they did that fox lift on me to open
up my eye and give me more of a feminine
touch so for me it was you know stepping
into my womanhood
and also it comes along great with the
whole beauty of you know
the winged eyeliner and all of that so
last time some person random person
commented on my pictures
and um you know when like editorial
models just post
like this and putting like their um
sites
someone was like oh can you stop
imitating an asian person and i was like
i'm just posing like a regular person
but like you know enhancing like the
brow
um the fox eye i don't think a lot of
people have the intent when they do the
fox eye like how you were saying lifting
your intent was not to offend or or
appropriate
asian culture if anything you were doing
it because you found it to be beautiful
yeah i think in a way it's not for me to
take a stance on like i am asian but
i mean you know remember asia is like a
big continent so like i'm south asian
i'm pakistani and so
nobody has ever made fun of my eyes
thankfully um but if i was east asian
it would feel more hurtful i don't
necessarily know what the answer is
if it's offensive but if somebody from
that culture says that they are harmed
by it that it hurts them that it makes
them feel lesser then i feel like that
should be respected
there is no harm in children using
makeup
so the way that i interpreted this
question was children doing their own
makeup
not having it done by someone older
or someone who's more experienced with
it i think that makeup within itself
is a self-expression and i feel that if
a young boy or a young girl is drawn to
that
then it should be supported and
treated with like love and kindness and
acceptance
i think it's totally fine
if a kid has conscious parents maybe
conscious friends
mentors teachers around them and they're
just playing with makeup
and your their intent is not simply to
please others i think it's
completely fine i've just noticed that
that doesn't tend to happen a lot of
times in society
i have three reasons why i disagree the
first one
is like i said my mom putting the makeup
on me as a child
and now you have this adult that feels
like she has to be presentable all the
time
that's a problem yeah the second one is
you know
causing acne i don't even think that
makeup causes acne
but if it's unnecessary and you don't
know how to take care of your skin then
you can cause a problem
the third one is because of herbs out
here i wouldn't want my little sister
wearing makeup so young because i
wouldn't want her to attract the wrong
attention
that was basically mine too yes i would
be so upset if like
my sister was younger and drawing that
kind of attention with lashes and making
herself
just look more of a sexual object online
kids can use makeup as an
art form too exactly so i wouldn't say
to just not
introduce it is there a certain age that
you guys think it's appropriate for them
to start wearing makeup i'll say puberty
well i went through puberty at 10.
i don't i wouldn't recommend it for me i
think at 15 or 16 is like a good age
because you're
like becoming that woman i used to work
at ulta so um
there would be like little girls just
coming in looking for foundation and
they were like seven or six
it was so weird because their parents
were like letting them but i mean that's
her kid i'm no one too
right to tell her not to do it or not as
a kid makeup
came into play obviously i was a little
boy
at the time i had a very strict
stepfather it got beat for everything
so my mom was just like my icon you know
so she would be doing her red lipstick
and getting ready for work
and she would leave and i would run and
get in front of her vanity and like i
put it all on and then i would look at
myself in the mirror and be like
everything and then i would hear some
footsteps coming down the hallway and
which i would book it to them
when i was trying to scrub it all off i
was never able to
do it obviously as a kid i guess i'm
making up for all that time lost because
there's not a day that goes by that i'm
not glad
yeah obviously there's a line of to
which like the degree to which someone's
doing their makeup with girls going to
ulta
and stuff buying like real like adult
makeup
is that a thing i don't know um as
opposed to like play makeup like barbie
makeup stuff like that
you have like a six-year-old client for
hair and
she has makeup palettes like from the
store and she's six
for a six-year-old to have multiple yeah
like no
i feel like it's also more intense too
though because like there's so many
tutorials on youtube
of like how to do makeup so these little
girls are doing sickening makeup
they are beat and powdered
there is such a thing as too much makeup
for me honestly putting any amount of
makeup on my face is too much
but i know for all of you three you guys
enjoy it so much
and so what's too much to me is by no
means too much to you guys
at the point where you start to not look
like yourself
excessive contouring where girls
literally look like they're changing the
bone structure of their face like
that's talent but like also that's not
you there's this growing tick tock
who is a bad influence is it the one
with the pouring and pouring and
pours foundation on her face pours it
and then
rubs it in but her outcome
is like normal yeah it's a normal
outcome and i actually saw a tick tock
of someone actually trying it
and she kind of washed off her face
after and breathed it on yeah
normal face the everyday person is gonna
go out and dump the foundation on
rub it in and then go on about their day
and look crazy i think it also plays
into
like being taken seriously like if
you're going for a job interview or
anything like this
like sometimes you need to step in and
be like hey sis you're doing your thing
but that's too much yeah like it's way
out of line like i'm a soccer trainer
so when i had my interview they told me
to show up in
soccer clothes because i had to like run
through some drills and stuff if i
looked like any of you guys
and you're like what are you doing like
but obviously like if you guys are
applying to work at like sephora or ulta
like they want to see you know how to do
this
every person has the agency to decide
what is too much
or not enough when i'm wearing a full
face of makeup i never wear foundation i
only wear concealer but like
10 years ago when i thought i had to
wear more makeup like a foundation
was like my full face i think it's okay
if it's kind of a moving needle for what
you prefer is too much or not enough and
people can give you
their opinion but it's ultimately your
choice to make
people have their own reasons for
wearing too much some people
do it to troll you know like probably
that girl that you were mentioning on
tick tock just
pouring on foundation she's probably
doing it just to be a troll and just to
be funny and that can be funny
i probably wouldn't think it looks good
but i don't think it's too much makeup
if it sits right with them
and they're doing it to get their laughs
out or it actually feels good
to them hey you know wear all the makeup
in the world you know
i think we're triggered because we're
artists in our craft
and it's our job yeah you know if you're
wearing makeup
we're gonna get we're gonna look at it
we're gonna look at it and we're gonna
look at what we would have done
differently
so when we see other people doing this
it's like oh no that's too much how
would you respond or how have you
responded when people give you feedback
about your makeup like
oh it's too much or like this is too
extra or something like that i just tell
them to go [ __ ] themselves
no seriously i have two sets of siblings
a group that wears makeup and a group
that completely doesn't
i get harassed by the one that doesn't
all the time my brothers they tell me i
wear too much
my sister she's like you got all that
makeup even down to now my nieces and
nephews comment on it
we're like why does it matter to you
guys like what are we doing to you yeah
i feel like mostly it's people that
don't wear makeup that are like oh my
god you're wearing too much makeup or
just have to
something to find to fix for someone to
sit there
and you know basically say like they're
against makeup and they don't have to
wear makeup because they're just
naturally you know gorge or whatever
it's actually a blessing in disguise for
them because out there in the world
there's
you know people that have their face
burned there's people that have scars
there's people that have
um blemishes and all kinds of crazy
things and they don't have a choice
maybe if they don't want to wear makeup
but they have to put makeup on to be
presented and accepted by society even
with skin care if i went
to that side of the argument it's a lot
of privilege to have the knowledge to do
skin care
to have the money and resources to do
that i used to have
and i still have like really painful
hormonal cystic acne
and i've spent probably thousands of
dollars on like laser treatment
like scarring ipl um and my mom is in
that business so i'm able to like get it
at a discounted rate but
literally like thousands of dollars
hours like driving
i don't even have a car taking a bus
down to where she lives i was asking her
like when will those treatments end
and she was like maybe never like maybe
for the rest of your life if you want
your skin to be clear
like this is what it takes and not
everybody can access that or even wants
to
[Music]
two